Italy was an interesting
actor in World War I
because it was one of the original members
of the Triple Alliance. In 1882,
Italy becomes a member
of the Triple Alliance.
The whole reason why it was called a
Triple Alliance is because it was between
Italy, Austria-Hungary and Germany.
Despite being part of that defensive pact,
that they would defend
each other if any of
these other parties like
Russia were to attack them,
or France were to attack them,
it was an awkward alliance because Italy
was a historical enemy of Austria-Hungary.
Austria-Hungary had some
territory, especially
some territory where some
Italian speakers were.
Some Italian nationalists
were interested in recapturing
or having claims on
some of that territory.
I've circled some of that right over here.
Right from the get-go it
was an awkward alliance.
Even in that first Triple
Alliance, Italy got
an exception for this defensive alliance.
It says we don't want to be
at war with Great Britain.
Then in 1902, Italy gets
into another secret ...
or I guess this is the first
of many secret deals ...
with France. If you've
ever played Diplomacy,
this is what Diplomacy's all about.
You make a deal with one
person, but maybe in secret
you're making exceptions
with other people.
They get into a secret pact with France
where Italy's essentially
saying, "Look, you know,
even though we're a member
of this Triple Alliance
and we've already said
we're not going to be at war
with Great Britain, we're also going to
say that for France as
well. We're really not
in a mood to be at war with you."
Then when you fast forward to 1914,
and we're now at the
beginning of World War I,
August, Germany declares,
July, Austria-Hungary
declares war on Serbia,
Russia begins to mobilize,
Germany declares war on
Russia and on France,
Italy, because of this kind of awkwardness
in this Triple Alliance, actually decides
to stay neutral. Italy stays neutral.
Their justification for staying neutral
is that the Triple Alliance
is a defensive pact.
It says, "Hey, we're
going to defend each other
if anyone attacks us," but they're saying
that in 1914 at the
beginning of World War I
it was Austria-Hungary that
decided to take the offensive.
It was Germany that took
the offensive, just based
on mobilization in Russia, that took the
offensive against France and in terms of
declaring war on Russia. So Italy says,
"Hey, look, this is a
defensive pact. The other
two members of the Triple
Alliance, they're being offensive.
We don't want ... That
means that we aren't
bound to it. We're only bound
to it in the event of defense.
As you can imagine, a lot of it was them
just trying to figure out
who's likely to win this,
in which scenario are they
likely to gain the most.
So you fast forward to 1915,
in particular April 26.
The Italians are
negotiating with the allies
thinking about what type of
territory they could capture
especially from Austria-Hungary.
On April 26 they sign
the Treaty of London,
which at this point is a secret.
Treaty of London. It's
not broadcast to the other
members of the Triple
Alliance, but it's an
agreement with the triple
entente that hey, look,
we are on your side.
We are going to declare
war on the central powers imminently.
They do so in May 1915, on May 3.
They back out of the Triple Alliance ...
out of Triple Alliance ...
out of Triple Alliance.
Then on May 23 they declare war
on their historical enemy, but one of the
co-signers of the Triple
Alliance declare war
on the Austro-Hungarian empire.
On the Austro-Hungarian empire.
As we'll see, this was actually, Italy's
entering into the war on
the side of the allies
against Austria-Hungary, actually played
a major role in the eventual downfall of
the Austro-Hungarians
and I'll go into that
into more detail in the next video.